yeah so he took out mr good and he took
out essen georgie so ss george he did
get the run back with hapon so he
actually doubled jeopardy japan out of
the tournament uh and then fell to rgn
right after that and then arjen over mr
good so here we are rgn versus sidestep
lance
okay now what do you think of this
matchup akuma versus lee challenge i
don't see this matchup every day
this is definitely not a match that we
see every day uh and you know
going back to lee being the back four
master like my question here is does
back four beat like demon flip does it
beat jump in like i feel like it
probably does it's the answer for
everything usually uh we'll see man i'm
curious to see how this one goes
okay
be super careful about that meters this
building up for rj and also especially
in the latter half of this uh
set decisive lands good block rgn down
[Music]
three slide fail
good whip punch with the doubt himself
there
oh no again so on point back to
he's been conditioning sidestep lance
with the down threes and can he continue
on to the wall yes look at this damage
that was beautiful that was perfect
combo there right it all started with
the count right upstairs got the balcony
break down there had the screws still
into the wall carry for the combo and
depth very nice round for rgm
is
closing the gap out with uh running 3-4
this is really good for him but so far
it's not working out rgn has him up
against the wall the wall bounces
next can he carry no he drops it
it's okay he's still got a huge lead
here tries to land some big trouble
uh right now it is everything going rg
in favor his timing on the defense has
been ridiculous
all right there's the slide
there it went inside that time
the timing just wasn't there and wasn't
enough for sidestep last rgn gets caught
out in the air
there you go
counter it down three and sidestep lance
we talked about it earlier being just a
little bit slow on the download right a
little slow starter picking up as the
set goes on and we're kind of seeing a
little bit of that again right now
yeah might be playing into the palm of
his hands those sides have plans he just
needs a bit of more time to download rgn
but rgn is playing so well against
sidestep plans it's insane ff3 catches
him off guard he's so close to the wall
though be careful
yeah he's got full meter now as well
nice side then
do attack we break here nice get the
break a little spanx
oh
with just a sliver of health takes game
one
that was amazing back and forth there at
the end you saw though you know size of
that started to put the pieces together
right the puzzle was almost complete
there so game two is gonna be really
interesting here uh the first couple
rounds are rough right you can see the
download there i really like the
adaptive adaptation that's coming out of
size to plan so far
but uh a little bit too late there and
you know down to the wire there uh it
was just unfortunate right cooper common
drops i feel like when you're playing
specifically in an online tournament and
you're going against an akuma right
anytime they hit you with a down to
combo you down back and you wait for
them to potentially whiff that combo
right because it's such a good strategy
right the potential for dropping is so
much higher so you gotta just hope for
that and he had an opportunity there but
he didn't he didn't expect to drop and
then he ducked after the drop and ate
the while standing too right so uh you
personally that's my personal strategy
if i'm going against an akuma online i'm
like he's going for a cobblestarter down
to i'm down backing i am down backing
that's uh that's pretty brave you know
that's pretty what if you get hit by the
the twin pistons so
he's gonna he's gonna stop his car we'll
do a twin piston no way you're right i'm
waiting for that effort he's gonna miss
or something
he's not gonna
look because i said it now they're gonna
know about it right but
they're not gonna know
all right somebody use shaheen
somebody use akuma against rip the next
time they dm and use a he's a twin
piston just for my sake
drop your combo intentionally and twin
piston me go for it
i'm looking forward to you know i'm just
going to stand guard now
[Laughter]
perfect
mind games through commentary game two
rgn sidestep lance
ah yeah forgot realm uh good choice here
and you saw it there why right the back
four he's like if you ever go airborne i
catch his back four we're going down and
getting the combo
yeah
the job isn't entirely the most um
reliable in this case because
he's a small character back four is the
most reliable you won't have the
the most reliable one you have o-r-g-n
gets away from the wall a risky
situation
didn't that meter yet couldn't do much
of that fireball
back four range is much better now
see that down back there you're down
back there as soon as you get your
fireball
you down back
but he didn't do anything come on i mean
yeah that's perfect if he did do
something and he missed you're great
maybe you got a point good lunch oh no
he missed it the f2 just by afraid he
missed the punish
whoa
you know that was a mistake for a
fireball probably there
bounce
i'm gonna go downstairs also big damage
coming from sidestep plans but tens of
thousands outside of rage good tech
catch my sides of flats and there it is
the armor rgn gets caught and this is
what we were talking about guys
with the downloads
yeah very good attitude
let's see if you can keep the momentum
rolling right now
it's almost like a comfort oh my god i
love it
i love it
coming from a llama like you rip i know
you would then here we go size of flask
let's hope he does more and rgn lopez
gets another combo in all worth it
where are we going can't reach the wall
here too far
range
takes it to a game three again don't
count this guy out just because he loses
game one he will take it to a game three
and you're seeing a lot of combos that
aren't fully executed right like a lot
of these something in f8c into nothing
uh mistakes that are happening and you
really have to take advantage of right
like obviously online offline there are
separate you have to treat them as
separate uh and again akuma specifically
you know i think he's starting to
recognize doing these fdc conversions
there's opportunities to be had uh so
we'll see if you can keep it together uh
but right now i think seismic lance is
looking really good in the set you know
we talked about it earlier the download
uh he's slow starter you know but once
you put the piece of the puzzle together
uh things start looking a lot better for
them so
it's looking a little rough for rgm
you might have to switch the stage
though because this is um sidestep
lance's comfort stage the forgotten rump
might want to go for you know some more
more honest stage like mishima dojo
maybe even go for the internet because
akuma still kind of works in the
infinite stage given you know
two two meters right
right yeah and akuma i feel like with
the wall though the damage potential is
so high you kind of just want to keep it
and with the tech catch potential
afterwards uh we already saw a size of
glance at some tech cats too probably
caught rgn off guard with it so you know
going forward obviously our gen will
probably be a little more cautious with
this tech rolls at the wall
uh especially in situations where the
wall combo isn't like a complete wall
combo right those usually tells that the
combo is lead to some sort of tech trap
and instead he goes for the dragon's
nest so a bit of a weirdly shaped stage
but there is still a wall present here
so it might work out better for rgn
considering akuma can dish out a ton of
damage especially with full meter
[Music]
well let's see what happens final game
here loser's bracket top eight action
no go
kick counter hit follows up with the
combo
rgn big damage is he gonna go for the
okay no it goes for full combo
hey hey chop him up
oh down three he's gonna fish for that
wall bounce again
[Music]
again that shop finishes him off rgn
with round one
yeah that four two one was back to the
wall like that was not the best call out
right there right
i'm not even sure like it didn't look
like it was for a whiff partner i think
so that was an odd choice besides that
lance uh but he really just gave the
round rgn with that no oh boy
yeah and again right you're seeing the
meter usage beautiful bait
that was wonderful
combo
yeah okay so fans goes for the okay
combo finishes off at a down three and
now one round a piece again sidestep
lands with a slow download
and he's taking it back
the beautiful slides are working
good down four i like that after the
back form surprise it reached oh no oh
my god armor
he doesn't even use the meter here he's
going to carry to the wall but he drops
the combo still carries sidestep wall
slides that plant to the wall and now
he's in big trouble what's the oaky here
wait oh my god no excuse me
while said to ant here stay with the
oaky slides good double rage 50 50 no he
tried the big sweep good defense from
rgn to hold on set point rgm
okay now what can sites the plants do
here goes for the okie on that slide but
no
wants to make him guess down three
counter hit and this is the follow up on
the combo fadc full combo
definitely
combo incoming tries for the wall bounce
empty jump on accident get them out of
there for a second but it's not gonna be
enough rj opportunity to close it out
right now raise more precise atlanta
not enough to kill 50 50. the chop's
blocked
why oh he whips
big whiff from side step lands
with punish from rgn on the down three a
bit of a questionable decision from
besides the plaster given the fact that
it wasn't enough range but you can count
on rgn to whip punish that perfectly big
props to rgn and you know
congratulations to sidesteplands for
making it this far but unfortunately he
is now eliminated
rgn is still in uh scythe of landscaping
yes uh rgn though man he looked really
good there uh and man that last attempt
from that it's just heartbreaking
because he he had the chance right like
he survived the combo he blocked the mix
up afterwards yeah you know he just
needed to do something with more range
you know in those situations it's kind
of hard to go out with rage too right
like especially have a rage drive like
lee like just kind of throw it out there
if it hits it hits you know you might
make the whole comeback with just that
but unfortunately